good weather is always good news for
blackpool and its tourism industry but
that industry is going to feel the full
force of the upcoming rail strike with
no trains in or out of the town for much
of the week the government do need to do
something the fuel price season
are going up
so people ain't affording to get here by
their own transport
and if they're if the rail strikes then
no one's going to be coming here
jackie mccann organises an annual
reunion here for former wrestlers like
herself she says people normally make a
long weekend of it three wrestlers today
have called off because they'll you know
they can't get back to london that's
going to have a big impact especially
for them as well they look forward to it
every year and it's only once in the
year
i mean the booked hotel
the walkout by rail staff comes at a
crucial time for this town blackpool was
hit extremely hard by the pandemic and
businesses that survived need the town
to be full of tourists all summer and up
and down the country this strike is
going to cause major issues for people
going about their everyday lives
like louis mckenna crisp who works for a
technology company in central manchester
he can't work from home and has no other
way of getting into the city i'm having
to use annual leave
for
a service that's striking that i don't
think is very good anyway the trains are
constantly delayed constantly cancelled
the customer service is poor there's no
understanding from any staff
although the strike is across three
dates if signalers and control staff
aren't working overnight shifts they'll
be knock-on disruption hitting travelers
across the week
and there's no sign of a last-minute
compromise to solve the pay dispute
between the union rmt and network rail i
think it's essential to modernize the
railway i don't think we have a choice
we have to deliver better services we
want to do that more safely and we want
to do it cheaper so um yeah it can be
difficult at times but we're going to
keep talking
and as other unions look at strikes
there are warnings of a summer of
discontent hitting workers holidaymakers
and anyone else who relies on the
railways becky kochel sky news